Throughout history different
cultures reference a great war
with worlds and species we
didn't even know existed
this war was known as mortal kombat
does that mean i'm gonna get
superpowers at any point it's all real
it has begun
for what for something known as mortal kombat
the fate of earth is in our hands get over here
throughout history different cultures
all over the world reference a great
tournament that dragon marking i think it's
an invitation to fight for something known
as mortal kombat i've always talked
about respecting the material
and respecting the fans they all deserve to
see their beloved characters elevated to this
cinematic height this really comes across as a
powerful experience that we haven't seen before
it's this grounded dramatic but silent tale
what is so striking about mortal
kombat is how expansive the story is
it's epic we have all the great
characters that the fans love
I'm sonya my name's jax that's kano
i'm lou kang kung lao lord raiden
the interesting thing about playing a video game
character is that you have to walk this line
of being larger than life but
also making that person real
there's actually rich emotional life behind every
single character we need to be authentic you need
actors who can perform the actual movements and
stunts it's mind-blowing what they do and i think
that fight element that has always been in the
game can be brought to life on the screen and it's
not for cg I promise you no matter how many of
my people you put in the ground we will not fail
i've always believed that something elegant and
beautiful can cohabitate with brutal and primal
all of the detail gives the audience a sense
of realism and connectivity to this world
the first time that i started seeing all of
these guys in costume i was blown away they've
completely brought all of these characters to life
this is more than just seeing a movie produced
this is seeing something that i've been passionate
about my whole life finally come to the screen
i love working on this kind
of international project
it really represents the mortal kombat world
i hope it's both a reward for
the fans and a new experience
don't be fooled that it's just a game it's more
than that it's cinematic it's beautiful there's
heart and there's emotion all those ingredients
together it should be a fun powerful ride
so enjoy get over here
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
mortal kombat trailer video they just released
a whole bunch of new footage so we'll break it
all down there's a bunch of easter eggs and we
got some clarification on what's going on with
the characters and where they're headed with
the movies like what's going on with this movie
relative to the rest of the mortal kombat story
because they are planning on making sequels if
this is successful enough there's enough mortal
kombat mythology for them to do like seven
movies if they wanted to they could go full
marvel cinematic universe with this if they really
wanted to i will be doing more videos for the
movie as it comes out in theaters around the world
so be sure to subscribe to get everything but if
you've been watching the mortal kombat series for
a long time you've seen some of the classic series
like mortal kombat scorpions revenge a lot of this
story does turn around the idea of scorpion in his
relationship with sub-zero during the film and
here's actually a really big revelation the movie
itself is actually kind of like a prequel to what
you would think of a traditional mortal kombat
movie whereas you know you go into a mortal kombat
movie they hype up the idea of this tournament
that they're fighting to defend earth realm from
outworld and shang tsung but in this movie they're
actually only working up to the events of the
tournament so it's more of an origin story for all
the characters including the cole character who's
kind of like the main character of the film even
though the movie's only been referred to as mortal
kombat technically the full title of the film is
moral kombat resurrection which is where we get
into the whole scorpion sub-zero relationship
so just confirming some theories based on the
footage that we've seen so far you see this
backstory in this fight between the original
version of scorpion in the original version of
sub-zero so they actually do show you scorpion's
origin story during the film he lived hundreds of
years ago and he was the member of a rival clan
of the original sub-zero whose name was b han so
bi-han wants to kill him he goes after his family
you see that play out in all this trailer footage
you see a lot of familiar scorpion easter eggs
like he picks up this spear that looks exactly
like the weapon from his special attack that comes
out of his hand later he's eventually killed by
bi-han in combat and then basically winds up dying
and passing into their version of the underworld
their version of hell however you want to think
about it for hundreds of years then in present day
you meet this coal character who's an mma fighter
like you see the yellow wraps around his hands
they're kind of implying that he is a descendant
of the original scorpion and i believe the way
they explain that is that hanzo had a daughter who
survived sub-zero's attack and was in hiding so
she went on to have a family of her own so that's
basically where the coal character comes from but
he doesn't know anything about his backstory he
doesn't know anything about the mortal kombat
tournament or this larger mythology that's why
they're sort of using him as a point of view
character in this first new film in the mortal
kombat series will hopefully be many mortal kombat
movies using him to introduce the main characters
in the larger mythology sort of spreading out from
there the same way the marvel cinematic universe
movie started out with the iron man film you start
out with the basic earth-based main characters
then slowly and slowly you go more and more cosmic
eventually revealing thanos the whole infinity
gauntlet storyline you get to avengers infinity
war avengers end game the mortal kombat series
does have their own version of that going on in
the background there are some familiar tropes
too like they even have their own version of
the infinity stone so i'll explain in a second but
the first few movies is basically just them doing
the initial storyline like setting up the whole
concept of the tournament the main characters why
are they fighting in the tournament what's going
on with the multiverse these other realms who are
the main antagonists who's shang tsung and who are
the villains that are behind shang tsung like each
villain serves another master who's more powerful
they teased that a little bit during this trailer
footage like you see shao khan's statue but you
don't actually see shao khan himself show up in
the flesh if you're a long time mortal kombat fan
you already know most of this backstory all the
mythology so you're probably confused about what's
going on with the cole person but like i said
mostly there for newer viewers who aren't
familiar with all the games all the mythology
and even though they're only hyping up some of
the core original characters there are many other
classic characters from the first few games that
show up during the movie that you just don't
really talk about too much during the footage like
a lot of you did spot reptile in the background
of some of these shots we see a little bit more
footage with prince goro cabal riko natara molina
all characters during the movie but if you saw the
original mortal kombat movies like the first movie
then the second movie the second movie isn't quite
so good so you don't absolutely have to watch that
it is a bit of an endurance test for hardcore
fans but in the first movie they basically do
the storyline from the first few games then in the
second movie they do the next part of the story
where you meet way more the outworld characters
you meet shang tsung's boss shao khan you learn
what his interest is in all this then i'm assuming
if everything goes well with these mortal kombat
sequels and they make enough money and they want
to continue making movies things will just slowly
go more and more cosmic there's been a couple
retcons they've introduced some really powerful
cosmic characters in the more recent games so i'll
explain sort of the relationships really quickly
here so the basic story just starts out with a
bunch of chosen characters that do have special
powers like magic does exist within the mortal
kombat universe it comes from this very cosmic
source you learn about a big tournament of realms
that they have to fight in to save their universe
earth realm from shang tsung in his master shao
khan in outworld there are many other realms
though that obviously they'll probably introduce
in other sequel movies so shang tsung himself is
a sorcerer who's working for shao khan shao khan
is the true ruler of outworld and he was formally
outworld's version of raiden so within earth realm
raiden is like a lesser god whose cosmic purpose
as ordained by the elder gods of the multiverse
is to be sort of an advisor for the chosen ones in
each new instance of the mortal kombat tournament
so within the context of this movie mortal kombat
resurrection raiden sort of explains what the
stakes are and why they need to train and win this
tournament shao khan is implied to be a lesser
god too as he's immortal and he was sort of out
world's version of raiden until the former ruler
of outworld wound up dying shao khan took over
and now he's basically using shang tsung in
his quest to conquer the other realms using the
tournament so the whole idea of the tournament was
actually created by the elder gods to create this
cosmic level of order in the multiverse they're
the ones that create all these rules that you sort
of learn about during this first movie like when
you're allowed to attack the fighters from another
universe then you have characters like shang tsung
who are always trying to break the rules so the
elder gods are like a boss here above the lesser
gods like raiden and shao khan the elder gods
themselves were created by the one true god of the
mortal kombat universe like if we're talking about
marvel cinematic universe comparisons that would
be the one above all characters so powerful that
you never really see them but they did exist
at one point here's where we get to the greek
tragedy of it all so the one true god created the
elder gods in order to use them as a food source
to sustain himself and then eventually the elder
gods wind up rebelling against him and breaking
his essence into many different pieces in those
different pieces become the different realms of
the multiverse along with their version of the
infinity stones within the mortal kombat universe
they call those the kamidogu so while you have all
this tournament stuff going on the machinations of
the lesser gods the elder gods behind it all you
have the essence of the one true god that's slowly
trying to reform itself so this one true god who
was defeated by the elder gods wants to reform
his body so that he can regain his control of the
entire multiverse which can only happen if all the
realms were to merge and the only way to do that
is for one realm to defeat all the other realms in
the tournament and collect all the kamidogu their
infinity stones the way the elder gods create all
these rules they try to make it impossible for
that to happen but you have other villains within
the mortal kombat universe that try to break the
rules in order to do that the main antagonist of
the entire series at least up until recently was
this evil fallen elder god called shinnok who
is crazy powerful but works more from behind the
scenes manipulating other characters like if we're
talking about scorpion and sub-zero he has his own
servant called quan chi his own version of shang
tsung who's a sorcerer that's about as powerful
as shang tsung who winds up manipulating bi-han
to kill scorpion's family setting up their whole
rivalry shinnok's whole goal is to take control
of the entire multiverse but in the very
recent mortal kombat games they actually
just introduced beings even more powerful than
the elder gods called the titans and obviously
more greek mythology references here in the new
game they reveal the titans in the mortal kombat
universe came before the elder gods but because
they're kind of a retcon addition to the mythology
the way they weave them in is that the lesser gods
like shao khan raiden the other characters only
thought the titans were myths in the mortal kombat
universe until they start to meet them in person
and the new main antagonist now of the entire
series is actually one of these new titan
characters they're supposed to be more powerful
and more ancient than the elder gods so as you can
see with all sequels things just keep escalating
with each new game in the franchise eventually i
think the idea of culminating in some sort of
cosmic war of the gods and that would be like
the mortal kombat version of avengers infinity war
in avengers end game so maybe the film franchise
if it's successful enough they'll be able
to work up to something like that so what's
going to happen is the mortal kombat movie has
actually been released in a couple international
countries now so some of you watching this may
have actually seen the movie already please
don't post spoilers in the comments the movie
is going to be released most places and on hbo
max on april 23rd in a couple weeks so it's not
that far away but if you have any big questions
about what's going on during the movie this
trailer footage or big easter eggs you want to
talk about just write them below in the comments
while you wait for everything click here for my